welcome everybody uh to
today's meeting of governance and audit
both
those that are participating and those
who are watching from home
if you have any technical difficulties
during the meeting
then please contact democratic services
officer on call
who will attempt to assist you today's
officer on call
is emily kennedy and the number to call
is 577046
i would ask participants when you're
speaking please mute your micro
ask persistence when you are not
speaking please mute your microphone
this minimizes background noise and will
help everybody in listening to the
proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly
indicate in the chat to the right side
of the screen
and i will then make a note and go back
to you once the person speaking has
finished
the meeting environment would
everybody present please ensure their
microphones
are turned to silent and they're not
used
their mobile phones are turned silent
and
they're not used to make or receive
phone calls whilst the meeting is in
progress
please also refrain from checking emails
on conducting
other business and ensure that you're in
a quiet room
free from discrete distractions for the
duration of the meeting
please note this meeting is being live
streamed
for members of the public the meeting
will also be recorded and will be
subsequently
broadcast on the internet
i now deal with the attendance
please i'll ask members of the committee
to confirm that they're present in the
meeting
when i read out your name i will ask
for the attendance of those counsellors
who are participating in order to speak
under council procedure rule 20.1
separately so i'll
read out the list of counselors who
should be attending councillor campbell
president councillor dexter
here mr chairman councillor boyd
councillor braidwood
president councillor crittenden
present councillor curry
councillor karina councillor garner
i'm present i have apologies for
councillor cook
councillor pat moore president
councillor shrub here chair and
council of towning
no country sorry i am here
okay prison
i haven't received any requests from
councillors to speak are there any
members
who would like to speak under rule 20.1
no yes please chair sorry chair
counselor
council ashby yes please
on um item eight
please item eight
thank you
item eight has been uh moved forwards to
the position of item five so you should
get that earlier councillor ashby
thank you chad i'll be able to watch my
football team then
right uh eight
we've only got one apology for absence
unless anybody else has any
apologies
are there any declarations of interest
no
[Music]
we now move on to the minutes of the
previous meeting held on the 4th of
march
copy attached to your agenda pack please
can i have a proposer and a seconder
unless i hear an objection proposed
counselor campbell
and a second uh
i'll second that counselor shrub
counselor shrub thank you very much
the minutes are approved yes
yes
agenda item 4 quarterly
internal audit update report i'll now
call on simon webb to introduce the
report please
thank you chair good evening members
this is our regular quarterly internal
audit update report
um summarizing the work of the internal
audit and department
on your behalf in the last quarter
together with the performance of the
scheduling partnership through to the
31st of may 2020
if i could draw your attention to the
table on page 13 that summarizes the
10 new audits completed during this
period
the majority of these were 2019
2020 audits that were finalized
in um march april and early may
um just as we started to enter into the
kobe period
very pleased to be able to report
substantial assurance and with very few
recommendations
for improvement in the areas of treasury
management
landscape marina insurance and
inventories of portable equipment
capital housing rents and printing
postage and photocopying we did um
record limited assurance in the area of
employee health and safety
at east kent housing um
that is an area that will be coming back
in house to danny district council
on the 1st of october and will come
under the
health and safety arrangements currently
in places within the council itself
so we will be looking for substantial
improvement in that area
and i am confident that that will take
place
at 2.8 in the table you can see we
undertook a very large audit of housing
repairs maintenance and void property
management
we split the assurance in that area
substantial reasonable and limited
um disappointingly it was limited
assurance
in the key area of housing repairs
particularly surrounding contract
management of the miya's contract
with key controls such as post
implementation
um sorry post inspections not being
undertaken
on a regular basis so we will be looking
for substantial improvement in that area
as i said um eastgen housing um the
housing service will come back in-house
on the first of october
under the council's direct control um
and so we will be looking at that area
again
after that date
2.9 um which is the turning page onto
page 14 of the agenda
um we undertook an um audit of building
control
we did conclude limited insurance in
that area but i feel it is an area that
should go up to at least reasonable at
the time of follow-up
which will be undertaken in the next
quarter
um at the time of audit field work
there were some changes in management
arrangements in that area
and management were in the process of
dealing with some of the control
weaknesses that were identified by the
audit so
whilst it's limited assurance it's not
an area of great concern to us at the
present time
providing we see at the time of
follow-up improvement
in that area as i've mentioned that
in previous meetings um follow-up
is a very important part of internally
work
three to six months after each audit we
go back
uh to see if the recommendations that
were agreed with management have been
implemented
and if i draw your attention to the
table on page 24
you will see that we undertook four
follow-up reviews during the current
period
um the first one in that list item a
tenant health and safety members will be
aware of the concerns
that have been had in that area for
quite some time
um and the referral of
this matter to the housing regulator
this was a follow-up of lifts the
original assurance
um at the time of the original it was
now assurance
unfortunately it was still no assurance
at the time of follow-up
we are going back um and undertaking a
second follow-up
that has started in the last week so um
by the time of the september meeting we
should be able to update you
uh just before the housing service comes
back in house on the 1st of october
hopefully with an increased insurance
level in that area
it is very important particularly
obviously as then it has more
high-rise blocks than some of the
surrounding
districts such as canterbury dover and
folkestone
so we will be paying particular
attention to that area
uh the audio of pci dss um it's been a
bit like um
painting the fourth bridge um that hold
it we seem to be keep doing that one
we are however nearly there um whilst
the insurance level is still reasonable
struggle limited
the outstanding areas are very very few
um and just a little bit more push and
take it up to holding reasonable
assurance
included as appendices to the
report is the planned progress
table starting on page 29 which shows
the days spent
on the 2021 plan that you agreed just
before lockdown
in early march and that includes the
days that we've
spent up to the 31st of may members
won't be surprised that obviously there
has been some disruption to the audit
plan
with lockdown with staff being
redeployed
into more essential areas during the
initial months of the
financial year um consequently the
figures at the 31st of may look
low i can however assure you that um
we are now auditing in earnest um
and have a good amount of audits
currently underway so by the time we get
to september
i think we would have made um fairly
good progress against the plan
considering the slow start due to covid
the other appendices are the usual ones
that you will
um have seen in previous quarters which
show the follow-ups that um we still
need to undertake
there is previously um concluded
limited assurance that's really just to
keep them on the radar so that you can
um see um that they will be coming
forward to future meetings
um that's it from me chair but obviously
you have to take questions on
any of the audits undertaken from any
members thank you
do members have any comments to make on
this item
uh chair councillor campbell
council go ahead council campbell okay
so i didn't put it in the bubble uh
yeah yeah thank you very much uh for
that uh presentation
uh my question was i almost answered
really the impact
of the coronavirus on your audit
um process and whether or not you'll
feel you'll be able to carry out the
full audit
uh throughout the uh the whole year
you'll be able to catch up
i noticed that it's had a severe effect
for the first three months
and whether or not as i say you'll be
able to carry that out mr webb
throughout the whole year
thank you councillor um it's slightly
early
um to be able to predict but i am um
very positively um impressed by the
amount of audits that have been green
lighted
in the last few weeks uh we do have
quite a lot of audits underway now
uh with more being approved each day
um the next item on the agenda tonight
is
the annual um internal audit report
um and obviously looking ahead to the
annual
internal difficult for next year
obviously we need to undertake
a reasonable percentage of agreed
plan to be able to provide you with an
opinion
um we did lose obviously
um certainly april may
due to covid and redeployment of staff
we have however um prioritized audits
from june onwards
that our audience that we could do large
largely remotely using technology such
as this
um to speak to officers
a lot of the audit testing can be done
remotely
other audits where we need to do
physical inspections of
properties or playgrounds that type of
thing we've pushed back into quarters
three and four
and hopefully um the lockdown measures
will continue to ease
and we will hopefully be getting back to
some sort of
normal as we used to understand that
word um
so it's a little bit early to say
categorically that um we're on target
but it's going very much in the right
direction
okay
[Music]
the reports uh i'd like to say the
reports received by members
and that any changes to the agreed 2021
internal audit plan resulting from the
changes
in perceived risk detailed at point five
of annex one of the attached report be
approved
please can i have a proposer and a
seconder
i propose councillor campbell councillor
campbell seconder
council dexter
nope sorry i'm i've had to turn my mic
off
um yes i'll second that proposal okay
that's proposed and seconded
no objections to that i'll uh take these
as approved
now we're moving on to item
eight as opposed to five um
i'll call upon christine parker to
introduce the report please
thank you chairman good evening members
um the page numbers that i've noted down
for the presentation are those that are
on
mod.gov i haven't got individual page
numbers for our reports within that so
i'll just refer to paragraph numbers
but do stop me members if i lose you and
you want me to re-orientate you on the
report
so firstly page 114 the covering report
to this year's annual report in
paragraph 1.1 it sets out the purpose of
the report
and the six bullet points listed are
very important for this
committee and u.s members in terms of um
us reaching uh demonstrating that we're
complying with our professional
standards to ensure quality and value
for money from
internal audit service but also with the
next item on the agenda which is your
annual governance statement
a lot of your assurances not all because
they do come from other sources but a
lot of your assurances will come from
the work of internal audit the detailed
look at the internal controls in
operation throughout the year
consequently the report is in two parts
then
part one covers um compares what the
internal audit service has delivered
against that which we promised
and planned to do last march um and how
well we have met
our professional standards and the
quality against our performance measures
in order for me to be able to provide
you with that opinion
i'll not focus on this part of the
report through the presentation but we
will come back to that at the conclusion
and the arguably more important aspect
of the report
describes the summary of the work
undertaken
the results and more importantly as we
talk about the so
what uh in terms of how well has
the identified control and risks that
we've raised um throughout the year
within individual pieces of work
being responded to by management what
control shift has that
uh actually achieved for the
organization and therefore how much
assurance does this provide the
committee
for you to be able to fulfill your
responsibilities
so if we take a sort of talk through the
uh report
um and the paragraphs that follow
within the main report in paragraph 4 we
give an overview
of the work that has been done so there
were 22 projects planned
and 12 were pushed back for various
reasons four
new ones were pulled forward with a
higher priority rating
and three um were working progress at
the year end
and additionally five were completed um
that were on the cost from april last
year into april
so the report takes two snapshots of the
results of all of that to work
and it is members a summary really of
all the four previous meetings that
we've held
so there's nothing new in the actual
reports themselves
the table of paragraph 4.1 shows that
87 recommendations have been made
in those reports and agreed uh
three were critical 37 were high risk
and 26 were medium risk
so 86 all of which have been reported um
to the committee
and then the second snapshot is in
paragraph 4.2
and that summarizes the assurance levels
over the reports
and that table uh concludes that 64
were either substantial or reasonable
assurance
we then go on and talk about the
follow-up and the progress report
in paragraph 4.3 i think we mentioned
before
we consider this to be the most
important aspect of our work
it's one thing to go in and take an
initial snapshot in time of what we find
on the day
but then we go back and ask so what
what's changed as a result of those
recommendations
and how much has that affected the
systems of governance and internal
control
and the risks have been all improved
so the results show that one of you had
a partially limited assurance after
follow-up
and that was escalated to the committee
during the year
and three risks were escalated that were
outstanding at the time of follow-up and
they were escalated to the committee
during the year as well paragraph five
goes on to provide provide an
overall assessment of the internal
controls from 1920
and the points to note there are there
were five new areas
in the year with a partially limited
assurance and these reviews will be
followed up in due
course so the table at paid paragraph
six
lists those and as mr webb was
explaining in the last report
they will show the annex to the
quarterly report until those follow-ups
have been done
and we'll come back to you with the
revised assurance
paragraph 6 goes on to raise any
significant issues throughout the year
and we mentioned in paragraph 4.4
a matter where there was officer
dishonesty and they
resigned and the theme of the limited
assurances in some of the key areas
that we have reviewed during the year
one thing there was some lengthy delays
in obtaining management responses to our
work
and of course we had taken into account
the world pandemic
and that effect is also of course noted
um
so as mr webb also has explained things
are starting to get back
but some of those delays are have been
lengthy and
um we have noted that thing
we're going to list the areas that have
yet to be followed up as we've mentioned
so the report also concludes the work
that's been undertaken for east kent
services
uh their full annual report is appended
at appendix
4 to your port and it comes to the
phanet
governance and audit committee because
planet hosts these kent services
um dover district council and canterbury
city council rely on the report being
presented
to you much in the same way as the east
county housing annual report goes to
housing board and you rely on it being
presented there
and of course those results are also
featured in this
in summary form in this report
so the opinion for east kent services
overall provides a reasonable assurance
and the annual report for east county
housing which was as i say mentioned
uh presented on through the east county
housing board on the 17th of june
um as members will know his kent housing
is being wound up
so this will be the last annual report
for east county housing that we present
and this concluded a limited assurance
and key risks noted in our work with
regards to contract management
and tenants health and safety and
they've been highlighted to this
committee
throughout the year as those reports
have gone forward
this leads me then to paragraph seven of
the report and my overall opinion
uh one point to note members as well the
definitions
in the definitions for our assurances in
my appendix one
are different to the definitions in the
quarterly report that you have just
received the reason for this is these
are the definitions for last year
and that's why it was important to make
that distinction from
april we have adopted the new sit for
definitions
they're not massively different but it
brings us in line with the new
professional standards
so all work from april this year we'll
go forward with those definitions
um i mentioned our performance against
target so i just highlight to members
appendix 5 which is the balance score
card
showing the performance against the
performance of our team
and that's the whole team not just for
the work that we've undertaken for vanet
um so paragraph seven and therefore
concludes a reasonable assurance overall
and this opinion is based on the
internal audit work completed
and reported to the committee over the
last four meetings
however i do have some small caveats to
this
opinion based on work that i've been
involved with during the year
which isn't completed and therefore is
not covered by this assurance opinion
i've raised concerns with the three
statutory officers
with bart thornton and with the chair of
the vice chair of this committee
and the matters will be resolved within
2021
and will therefore be reported in either
annual reports or annual government
statements
this time next year effectively
so the report is received before
receiving um
the committee is provided at paragraph
two with two options the members can
consider and note the report
and members can consider registering
their comments with cabinet in
respective
any areas of the council's corporate
governance risk or control frameworks
for which they have ongoing comments
after considering the work of internal
audit
thank you chairman i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you the i have a counselor
mike garner on the list would like to
ask a question
hi yeah hi thank you thank you christine
um yeah i've got a couple of questions
that i'd like to ask about
uh from a couple of areas in the report
if you don't mind
um the first area i'd like to ask you
about
is um going back to section 4.4
which you briefly touched on but at the
end there
you mentioned um a
whistle-blowing fact-finding matter
which
um was not fully concluded in the air
would it be possible i've got a couple
of questions about that
firstly um do you consider this a
serious matter
and would it be possible for you to just
tell us maybe a little bit more about it
and then also um do you think
when you think that will be completed
that fact-finding
um matter that you you're you're
progressing
and if not what is stopping it what is
stopping you completing that if anything
and just one another do you think it's
appropriately prioritized within the
council
the progression of this piece of work so
if i
just stick to that for now thanks
thank you thank you mr chairman um yes i
think the matters are very serious
and i think there has been um
a full and thorough um
commissioning of some work to be
undertaken to understand what those
issues are
and for those to be resolved um in terms
of how that moves forward at this point
um it would appear there have been
other sort of factors um
the council has received um i guess if
you go back through the stages through
the process
uh this links into some of the concerns
i have in terms of governance
in terms of matters being resolved in a
timely matter and following process
i think in public session counsellors
there's not very much detail that i can
go into
in terms of when it might be resolved
and why it hasn't been resolved before
now
but i'll ultimately to say that those
are those are the matters that i have
raised concerns around
thank you okay thanks if there's just
another
area of concern if you if you don't mind
i'd just like to ask you about
and that is in section five
um you mentioned in there themes
themes or emerging evidence of
management override
can you just explain just in layman's
terms maybe what that means
um so as we can better understand that
what that is
please thank you mr chairman thank you
for the question
yes in terms of good governance of
course what we are encouraged to
understand
is that we have um procedures and
controls
and processes that direct uh and control
a council's functions and it's our
expectation
that when we go in and do our testing
that we can obviously pick a sample of
transactions
and ensure that they have followed the
procedures and
the processes that were are expected
um i think the the work that is um
leading to these concerns or these
thoughts is when
those processes and controls aren't
followed and there may be
numerous reasons why that is the case
but i think
grant thornton have a risk in their
planning work and they looking for
management override of control so
this is the normal expected process and
how often
is that not followed for whatever reason
and then they would test for that as
well so it's something that grant
thornton
predominantly would be testing for but
in terms of our work
the concern is that um policy and
procedure is consistently and
effectively followed and that's the
evidence that
we're noticing thank you okay
okay just just one final thing
um in appendix two
i think you've got um 25 days spent
um investigating the whistle with a
whistleblower investigation
um is that all allocated to the one that
you mentioned in 4.4
where the employee um has left
um or exactly does any of that
or is there some of that that relates to
ongoing investigations
and also like it will there need to be
more
uh man or person days allocated to
whistleblowing investigations and if you
think there is then how many do you
think that might be
sorry there's a number of questions
there thank you i think i think
yeah thank you very much thank you
chairman um yes so in the
table uh the council refers to there are
two
areas one with investigation with 10.37
days that
that is the one where the officer uh
allegedly was dishonest
and left and the other matter with the
25 days
is a matter where i was asked to act as
a commissioning officer to look into the
whistleblowing
matters and that work commenced in
august
last year oh so all that that okay so
there's
this two so the 25 days doesn't include
any of that um
for the one where the officer left
that's all to do with the one that we
talked about in
at the beginning of this in football
correct thank you yes
okay thank you thanks for the uh thanks
for your answers on that um
that's all i've got for now thank you
very much we have a
councillor campbell would like to ask a
question if you'd like to go ahead
well yeah thank you chair yes councillor
garner asked the question about
management override i just wondered what
it was but
you fully explain that um as that's been
explained i'd just like to thank you and
your team
for an extra another excellent year of
of audit and uh thank you very much
particularly
discovering the failing of east kent
housing in the safety
uh situations that you discovered last
year
which really put us on our metal thank
you very much
thank you thank you and your team thank
you
and now uh councillor ashby would you
like to speak under
thank you chair yes um
i'd like to refer to um 4.4 um
i know you mentioned about about this
but um what was the financial
irregularity if you could
uh outline that um you mentioned that
the officer resigned
but um i'm not sure as to why that would
stop
um an investigation and maybe a
prosecution
um why wasn't the investigation followed
through
um councillor ghana asked the point
regarding the whistleblower
um i would just like to know where
exactly is the blockage in in the
process or in the system as to
why it's taken so long to move that one
forward
um item five um
again that was covered by council of
ghana and i think that
um
i'd like to you know is a serious matter
so i'll be happy that um
that that has been fully covered um and
lastly on
paragraphs uh item seven
um you you mentioned the reasonable
assurance and
do we not feel that that is quite a low
threshold and when was the last time you
actually concluded
reasonable assurance and what are the
instances in
in weaknesses in the anti-fraud and
corruption and whistleblowing
and if um we regard this as
a low threshold and what are we actually
doing to
maybe beef up the process and um
try and raise raise the bar on that one
thank you chair
thank you
thank you um what i can probably say
about the allegations
um in the case at 4.4 uh they were
largely
um excuse me um breaches of financial
uh procedurals and the but more
importantly the principle
of internal check where one officer is
required to
um prepare work another officer
obviously
are required to authorize expenditure
and the the controls around that were
the main controls
that have failed i think it's important
to note um
that the controls around budget
management
and the procedure rules there were also
ones where you were the
matter to have reached its hearing and
it didn't
so we can only talk about what obviously
the fact finding reporter got to a point
of trying to conclude
was um whether or not the
uh the the officer had abused their
position
in that regard in terms of their
authority
to make those payments um against that
budget heading
so it was very much um around
uh breaching the financial procedure
rules and whether it was a matter of
fifty pounds or five thousand pounds
it's the same principle and um
obviously the officer uh resigned before
the hearing
um so the matter was not concluded in
the sense of taking it forward
to either determining that they had or
hadn't reached the rules
and then the next step had that happened
then the next step may have been
a referral through following the policy
uh through to the police um clearly
those steps didn't happen as we didn't
reach the hearing
um so moving forward in terms of why the
whistleblowing hasn't been resolved
um it's um something that maybe
one of the other officers might like to
come in on um
in terms of the council has received uh
so
it received a whistle blow it
commissioned a
fact-finding investigation which would
have been an outcome report
the council has received an outcome
report and it is arrangements around how
that outcome report
is and the recommendations within that
report
are taken forward that is the point
where it has not
moved forward since january of this year
um i don't know the reasons
i've been we've had the world pandemic
there's many i'm sure there's multiple
reasons
um and um your last question is around
the threshold of reasonable assurance
i think you know what we're trying to
say
in that whole uh paragraph is we can't
give absolute assurance
um with many a time we've looked at a
system before i mean one of one of our
considerations when we look at risk
is what do we know about this when we
last stored it and what's changed since
is it the same system the same people
what can we expect and we can go in and
have a complete shock sometimes
everything's gone completely wrong since
our last audit
um so it is a snapshot in time it can
only be really valid from the day that
we're there and
the findings that we make so we can't
give absolute assurance
and we hear about things we heard about
one
in the briefing and it's the following
the report um later
on the agenda where somebody was on
holiday and somebody else covered and
an error occurred so those things can
happen with control systems of course
um especially when we're dealing with
people and computers
so it is for the council just to
determine where they want their standard
to be
i think a reasonable assurance is the
reasonable assurance in that sentence
is all about the management of taking
note
they're receiving our reports they're
responding to the
control risks that we find there's
obviously there's a drafting process
um in terms of we think this is a risk
do you agree what are we going to do
about it
those are the recommendations before we
assign a due date and a responsible
officer
so it's then measuring how well they
have been implemented when we go back to
the progress report and us expecting
those things to have moved on
and in that time so that we can report
back and say
yeah there were some issues they've now
been resolved you can have
a reasonable assurance that that process
is working well
um so in terms of we haven't
i don't think of course uh the
partnership issued a substantial
assurance across the piece
um i think it would be unusual for us to
do that
to find we have pockets of excellence
everywhere but it probably isn't across
the piece
i hope that answers your question but in
terms of your
confidence that management take note of
our findings and respond to them
then that is a that is a strong message
that that is happening
thank you
councillor ashby did you have it
sorry chair um yeah i mean the the only
point is um um the officer that is
resigning
um would somewhat indicate that maybe
there was
um an element of guilt there so i just
wondering i mean
having been involved in my career
before the fact that you resign you know
the fact of the matter is there might
still be
an illegal act there so um i just wonder
why
it couldn't have been taken forward if
it i mean regardless like you say
whether it was 50 pounds or 5 million
pounds it's irrelevant the fact that
someone has committed an illegal act so
did we not feel that it was an illegal
act it was just
a breach of maybe system procedure or
control
as opposed to an illegal act because it
if it was a legal act then
surely it needed to be going going
forward just to set an example
um that the council is not willing to to
tolerate that
type of of action thank you
all right chairman can i just come in at
that point just to make clear that
somebody's resignation you know
it isn't to be taken as uh a
symbol of guilt i don't know that's
that's wrong but nevertheless
you know there was a process set up she
actually resigned before the process
could begin
so we weren't able to actually define or
come to a conclusion
about her innocence and guilt so on that
basis then
once you leave you cannot let me
discipline because you're no longer an
employee
uh then
then mr house what's the situation about
pulling in
police or the decision whether or not a
criminal investigation should be taken
uh that was looked at i think at the
time
and due to the circumstance of the case
and i don't want to go into any further
this
viewer was taking that that was that
that was not appropriate
there was no requirement to do that but
the other given the circumstances that
wasn't appropriate
i think i've got councillor campbell
again on the list
no i've already spoken thank you
well this reports going on to
cabinet i believe which i think is a
good thing
these issues need to be dealt with i've
never seen quite so many
come along in one uh one meeting
having been on this uh committee for
many years
uh we'll move this uh
can i uh have a proposer and a seconder
for this item please
i propose councillor campbell
and our second council dexter
as we have uh no other objections or to
this that's
and and just to make it just to make it
clear mr chairman
that this the eye is going to be forward
um
to cabinet this issue
[Music]
is that correct that's the uh that's the
position at the moment
thank you okay that's fine
i now move on to agenda item five
annual government statement
thank you chairman yes this is the um
annual government statement and there's
um
as the intelligence has already said
this draws together
uh a lot of information from from the
internal audit team
as well as information from other teams
and about the government's work
undertaken by various committees of the
council
it does set out the key governance
issues and concerns at the end
and with an action plan for improvement
um
i should say i did make one error in i i
wrongly copied over the
section the report which deals with the
significant issues and overall
conclusions from the
internal annual report so the version
which will go forward will include those
um matters which you've already seen in
the previous report
so it's here for an agreement it'll then
go on to our
external auditors who will consider it
to make any necessary amendments before
it gets published
all right
do members have any comments to make
yeah just just one uh brief comment
from from page four of the report really
uh
about council it mentions uh um on the
11th of july
council agreed to um
four groups work together to to look at
a system of governance um
and that nothing has been fed back on
that yeah
um i don't think i don't think there's
been a great
a great deal of impetus given to this
and
sufficient support i don't believe from
um council officers to to help
that group that was set up actually do
that um would it be possible
this may not be the appropriate form but
would it be possible actually
to get some officer support for that
group of councillors
um to to progress that um piece of work
please
yeah so if i can reply to that point um
the decision of council was very
specific
when it said that actually it was going
to be led by
members and they didn't want officer
imports so the decision of council was
that the members would go away
and consider it without officer input
and then come back at some point so
that hasn't happened so they
specifically did not
want officer imports okay i don't
okay well i'll get back to that
committee um toot sweet
and um make sure that they get any
requests they might be
required in thank you
okay the committee's asked to agree the
draft annual governance statement
2019 20 which will be shared with our
external auditors
for amendment if necessary prior to
publication
please can i have a proposer and a
seconder
i propose mr chairman thank you
oh second councillor campbell okay
i hear no objections so these are
[Music]
approved
here we go
[Music]
we move on to agenda item
six accounting policies uh well
chris blundell introduced this report
please
thank you chair so this paper that's out
with counting policies
that the accounts will apply for the
2019-20
final accounts and also uh proposes the
accounting properties for the 2020-21
accounts
in addition also gives an update on how
the closure of this
account is progressing so just a bit of
a a recap what are accounts and policy
so effective they are the principles
conventions rules practice and method
that the council applies when we prepare
and present our financial statements for
the committee to consider
so for example they might set out how we
value our assets or recognize our
pension liabilities
so they're a fundamental part of our
accounts which the committee
is responsible for approving so the
purpose of this paper is to bring them
here in advance of that
in case there are any questions that the
committee wanted to ask before they
are presented as part of the accounts
for overall approval of the
statements for that year uh i don't
intend to go through the
individual accounting policies because
they are quite lengthy but i'm happy to
take any questions on them
either individually or collectively the
individual
accounting policies are set out and the
annexes to uh the paper
that details the policies we want the
committee to approve
elementary agenda items there is a
typograph typographical error that
needed to be updated
the only minor amendment that's actually
been proposed to
the 2020-21 accounting policy
is an increase in the minimum limit for
capital expenditure
and that's increased from 10 to 15 000
pounds so from
april 20 onwards that means any
expenditure below
15 000 will now be considered revenue
even if it meets the other definitions
and
criteria in order to qualify as capital
moving on so changes to the statutory
deadlines for the closure of accounts
um typically at this this july meeting
the committee would be approving our
final accounts not just our council
policies
however due to covert 19 these deadlines
have been extended for one year only
um the changes that have been made are
that the committee will now
have to consider the accounts for
approval
prior to 30th november for this year so
we will need to arrange an additional
committee meeting to consider that
closer to the date
we now intend to publish our draft
accounts on the 27th of august
and we will commence public inspection
from the first of september
so in some um the paper is asking
committee to approve the accounting
policies and also note the changes to
the statutory
uh statutory deadline for closure
accounts happy to take any questions
are there any questions on this item
in that case uh can i have a proposer
and a seconder please
thank you um
i'll take these as approved and
introduce
item seven
the in-depth insight into the impact of
kobit 19 on financial reporting in the
local government sector
again chris blundell i believe
thank you chair if i could actually pass
um
counselors over to sebastian evans from
grant thornton who will
talk the committee through this paper
okay
excellent um thank you can can you can
you hear and see me just to double check
before i begin
yes yes excellent thank you
um so as as you're aware there is a
separate
paper at the um at the end of this
agenda
which of talks in slightly more detail
about
um how the sort of impact of covert 19
will apply
inconnect in connection with the audit
but we've also
we also sent um saint chris over earlier
this year was essentially of a
publication grant thornton
have made which sort of talks through um
so some of the areas um which
could potentially have an impact on the
on the authority or indeed on all types
of authority essentially
within the local government sector and
i'm not necessarily planning to talk
through the detail of this but um
but in summary what what this deals with
is
i think some of some of the financial
reporting considerations
um so with respect to some of these were
recent events
um both in terms of your 31st
of march um accounts which year end
um but also i suppose for further
commentary on
things of the difference or potential
issues which might have an impact in the
future as well
um and and that you will see at the
bottom
if you have any sort of further
questions on this uh we do have a team
who will be able to provide responses on
that
um that being said of course is this is
an area which
is sort of quite integral to our audit
um as that as i'll describe in the audit
plan addendum
being presented later there are specific
additional procedures which we will be
looking at both
both in respect to the overarching risks
presented by
of covert 19 um but also in terms of
work streams which we would be doing
anyway for example such as
looking at the valuation of property
plant and equipment
but considering the impact of government
19 on things such as the
assumptions around the valuation of
assets and
given a lot of the sensitivities around
sort of valuation
arising as a direct result of
of course 19 restrictions that's
that's a summary i'm happy to take any
questions
i have nobody on the chat board would
anybody uh have any questions or
no uh yes i'll put a notice me please
yeah check no yeah at the bottom that
sorry carry on
uh yeah thank you uh mr evans uh this
seems to me more a sort of
general uh overview of the effect of
covered on local government
uh can you give us any particular ideas
whether
the covid has specifically affected
adversely fannit
thank you yes um so one of the items um
they'll sort of partly be covered i
think as part of
agenda item 11 at the end
um but i think in terms of the general
approach
on our audit and i think the first thing
to note
is that for this year a a lot of the
a lot of the changes that will sort of
such as um
additional funding received from
government and the impact of that on the
accounts
won't be felt until the subsequent audit
year um i
sort of year commencings of the first of
april 2020 i think simply because
the period of lockdown um being asked
around eight days at the end of march uh
was relatively brief
um but the sort of areas where we would
do specific procedures
um would be things such as say um
account accounts receivable um then
there might be sort of
because that has to take into account
future information based on say the
recoverability
of debt then that that is an area which
we would have to look at and and again i
think i think that applies a little more
generally sort of rather than
specifically to than it
um but i suppose with any sort of areas
you particularly had in mind with
respect to thanet
come back councillor campbell only that
uh obviously we are a
seaside town a seaside district and uh
the
impact upon uh visitor numbers and
revenue streams and other
uh issues that may impact adversely
uh to to thanit and other seaside towns
but particularly thanit
will be of interest
okay counselor ashby you have a question
council rash
[Music]
it's frozen okay
i suppose you could go to someone else's
chair and then maybe come back to there
yeah there's nobody else on the list
chair i wonder if i could just help with
p uh councillor campbell's
um question of sebastian evans
yeah what i would say is that the
july 30th um cabinet agenda
is published now just published today
and that includes um our estimate of the
financial impact
of kovid 19 on the council's finances
for this financial year
it does right
any any luck with currency
um i'm here we can hear you having
trouble turning my microphone
okay
maybe come back here i think everyone
can hear you can't
you're my conference on councillor ashby
it it might be that we have to move on
uh chairman
um let's see she pops up again now
uh members are being asked to note this
report
noted no geez
we now move on to item 9 quarterly risk
management report
would tim wills introduce this plea
willis thank you
um yes this is the normal quarterly
risk report um it sets out the main
corporate risks of the council
members will see that there's a new risk
that's been added this quarter referring
to kovid19
i'd also draw attention to the fact that
the pandemic has increased pressure on
the council's finances
although this hasn't changed the risk
score in respect of
finance since the last quarter and
also kovi 19 has the potential to
complicate preparations for brexit
but this is at this stage difficult to
quantify
i'm happy to answer any questions on the
report yeah
okay uh do members have any comments to
make on this item
could i have a proposal and a seconder
then please
offer pose counselor ghana thank you
second it counts again oh that's right
i'll cancel the dexter
dude okay thank you
i'll take this is approved
and we can move on to item 10
treasury management out team report
chris blundell could bring this report
to the military thank you
no thank you chair sorry i just had
difficulty
i'm meeting my mic there uh yeah this
this report is part of our
important cycle on our treasury
management activities
so this is a backwards look and how we
perform during
1920 as i was explaining earlier um
our final accounts haven't been
completed yet so the numbers
were contained in this report are
provisional still if there are any
significant changes we will subsequently
bring this report back for further
consideration but they are
um proposed for members approval as they
are in their current form
um so contained within the report there
are a number of performance indicators
that we have to report against from a
statutory requirement
um the kind of the reports separate the
two main parts
one's around our cash flows and how we
how we manage uh our cash and
that's and sure we have enough cash in
the bank to pay our bills and then we're
investing our services
wisely and the other aspect of treasury
management is around how we fund our
capital program
um so capital program deals with
expenditure items
uh written to acquisition or investment
in their assets such as buildings and
vehicles
and when we talk about um how we fund
our capital program we think about how
we're paying for that investment in our
assets so that's typically from
borrowing or from the proceeds from
asset disposals
so taking you through report the report
section three when we look at capital
expenditure you'll see there's been an
underspend
significantly against both the general
fund and the housing revenue account
budget so we had budgets
in the year of 36 million pound but only
spent around 17 and a half
million of that so this is this is
actually
a bit of a historic trend that needs to
be tackled and we'll be looking at going
forward
anticipated probably will be further
slippage in the capital program
in 2020 21 because of
covered and related pressures on the
organization
the actual detail behind those
understands will be reported to
cabinet as mr willis explained earlier
there's a report going
to cabinet in july but also subsequently
there'll be further reports in september
we'll have even more detail
on um our draft out term position
so beyond that section four looks
at our borrowing need um and this is
this section explains what our borrowing
needed or what's often referred to our
capital requirement capital finance
requirements so
i like to think of it as the balance
payable or outstanding
on the debts that we've taken out to buy
our assets so
um one of the requirements we have is to
con
to conform with that set up and it's
about to is that our capital finance
requirement
where i need to borrow should not be
higher
in the short term at least and the
actual debt that we have um
that we're borrowing that time so the
good news that i can report is that
that we were only holding at the year
end 25 million pounds of debt
and that we actually had total future
debt repayments left to make of 50
million
pounds so that might lead you to
question how we're going to make up that
difference
uh the shortfall between the two and
this is explained a bit further in
section five but the answer is
is the fact that we're doing something
called under borrowing or we are under
borrowing
and that factor is using our reserves
and any money that we hold
instead of going to banks externally to
finance that debt
uh section 4.7 um
that that's another statutory um
requirement they have to report on so
the authorized limit is the maximum debt
that we're allowed to hold during the
year
so i'm pleased to report that the
maximum debt that we're holding was 30.5
million
and that was well below the 103 million
pound structure limit
taking a quick look at section five
territory management position
um i've already spoke about the debt so
i won't go over that in too much detail
apart to say that you can see that
pretty much almost all of our debt that
we hold is with the public works loan
board
pwlb the exception of that is this 4.5
million that's placed with barclays
and there's two 20 thousands placed with
another
um institution that is called
science and that's around energy
efficiency that's why the interest rate
attached to that debt is zero
um table 5.5 shows when we expect
to repay our debt over the next 50 years
the profile repayment
moving away from debt in terms of
investments this section shows that at
the year end we had 33.9 million pounds
worth of investments on our book
so that exceeded the 25 million of gross
debt that i mentioned earlier by about
8.9 million pounds so you consider we're
in a net investment position
at year end table 5.6 also shows the
types of investment that we place our
money in and you can see that they're
very low risk
type of investments of money market
funds and fixed turn deposits
section 6 this gives an overview of how
interest rates have changed during the
year and the
sort of the overall investment
environment the key takeaway from this
section is that we've
kept our investment balances low again
as i've mentioned earlier by using our
reserves and balances to support
this internal borrowing rather taking on
external debt so if we if we borrowed
and uh externally that would have
boosted the amount of cash and our
investment balances would have been
higher but
the report sets out and explains the
reasons and benefits that we've actually
used this
under borrowing internal borrowing
position instead
6.2 talks about the borrowing strategy
and how boring changes in a year there's
a
few charts and tables in there
explaining how the pwlb rates moved
during the year
uh and the pwp ratchet should say is how
uh what we tend to borrow at members
may note there was a one percent
increase in the pwlb
rate in october this was partially
reserved on the 11th of march and so
more information how those rates change
there's been some consultation on the
use of pwrb
fundamentally government is consulting
on
much greater restrictions on the amount
or even the facility uh being available
for local authorities to invest from the
pwb to support commercial investment
there's something we don't think will be
available
going forwards section seven borrowing
out turn
so no borrowing was actually undertaken
during a year
we repaid 50 sorry 5.4 million pounds of
the debt
as shown in the table and the average
interest rate is 3.8
on the debt we're holding section eight
so key things to note in the report so
um
christine parker mentioned earlier
around how there can be
a failure of uh internal controls
so there was a substantial assurance
excuse me
on our treasury management that was
reported early year but actually there
was a failure of control
that i need to uh report where we
breached our overdraft limit because of
the clerical error
where one of our officers that uh
usually deals with
our daily investments was um on
annual leave and the officer that
usually covers them was sick and then
another officer
who was supposed to be covering them
effectively failed to
undertake the daily banking tax which
resulted being overdrawn for a day
um this was despite all the controls
being in place that was satisfactory the
procedure rules there are appointments
of people's diaries to this task it was
just
pure human error um the other thing that
i need to report in this session is
from april onwards although it's not a
backwards look but it still needs to be
reported
our county party limit with our main
bank was exceeded but this was because
of exceptional operational circumstances
um because we received a huge um huge
sum of money came into our accounts
around 40 million pounds
to deal with relief to provide to
business in respect to covid support
so that meant that one particular time
we were holding balances that were in
excess of the seven million pounds are
allowed to hold
one counterparty but that was deemed um
acceptable
and uh due to the operational
circumstances
uh just finally and then so you can see
um on average we held
46.3 million pound during the year of
our in terms of investments and we've
got a interest rate of 0.8
that's significant below the average
rate three point eight
that we're paying our brushes again
supports the strategy of why we tend to
use our reserves and balances instead of
going out to the market to borrow
we have to uh section nine just to
finish off just talks around some of the
risk benchmarks that we've
uh please report that we have met before
happy to take any questions
do members have any questions or
comments to make on this report please
i just can't see okay so um
this committee uh the recommendations
are
notes the actual 29 20 prudential
treasury indicators in this report
approves this annual treasury management
report for
2019-20 and that we recommend the report
to cabinet and council
please may i have a proposal in a second
i'll propose thank you and a second
council accountable seconds guys thank
you
these are approved
moving on to item agenda item 11
external audit plan update um
i now call on sebastian evans to
introduce this report please
thank you um you you will recall
uh the start of march when we were last
here in person
um sarah einemunga presented the audit
plan
um which set out at that time our
high-level approach um to um to the
audit um and i think it is worth
emphasizing if i go through the addendum
that the vast majority of the work that
we'll be doing
um does essentially sort of stay the
same in so far as far as the
the overall structure of how an audit is
done remains
the same even in this new environment
and
what will tend to be the largest and
highest risk balances
will continue to be the largest and
highest risk balances
um and those will be the areas where we
focus the majority
of our work um that being said
um the addendum would attach does
formally set out what we think the
impact on our audit and
value for money work is the first thing
i think as chris mentioned earlier was
the sort of fact that
there have been changes to the timeline
and me and the team have
met met with uh chris and the accounts
team um just towards the end of last
week just to work out what's going to
work
um just in terms of when we perform our
year-end field work
but also thinking about practical
arrangements um
such as how do we actually sort of work
well remotely
luckily we do do already have some
experience of this having
recently completed the nhs external
audit
season and so things of good practice
which we've learned from there
will be as were used um as part of this
order and other local government audits
as well um
so i think a lot of the areas in here
are supposed thematically quite similar
to the sort of things which you would
have seen in item seven
um earlier and but just in terms of the
specifics if i can
draw your attention to sort of page
five of um of the report
and what what this does is i think it
sets out sort of why we think
um sort of the covert 19 to represent a
specific audit risk
and specifically for what additional
procedures will be sort of performing
in relation in relation to that i'm
happy to take any questions on this
does anybody have any questions on this
item
or comments
no i think we're clear
members are requested just to note this
report um
so i consider we julie noted it
hello no dude
thank you that uh
concludes the business for tonight's
weekly
uh i declare the meeting closed at
6 12. um
thank everybody for participation thank
you and uh
for those watching from home the live
streaming will now end
and thanks to all of you good night